you
[Music]
it's a pleasure to have Don with us Don
Woodard leads data science for uber maps
which is the mapping platform used in
ubers rider application driver app and
decision systems including the pricing
and dispatch the themes technologies
that she's overseeing include roadmap
and points of interest definitions map
search route route optimisation travel
time prediction which we know we can
confirm me do you understand deeply and
do a good job with at navigation so Don
did her undergraduate work at Stanford
in math and CS and then went off to Duke
well she did a PhD in statistics and
then she became a faculty member in in
ORN information engineering at Cornell
where she worked on a number of projects
including Ambulance decision support
systems optimization of I guess
placement for ambulances including but a
variety of interesting projects even in
medical statistics performance
assessment for radiologists was looking
over your papers it's now I didn't even
know you were in that field between
working that field earlier after you
should get a tenure at Cornell and she
came to MSR for her sabbatical that's
where I got to know her so we actually
were delighted to to to provide dawn and
her student at the time with the family
and a home up in Seattle and I think it
was it worked out really well we had a
lot of fun working on with Paul Kosh and
John some on doing predictions with with
traffic predictions of forecasting with
Bing data and at the time being was
quite generous with with data sets and
with helping us with with that research
project it's kind of extended clear flow
the clear flow effort which is now
shipping worldwide and we were surprised
to find out that chief instead of going
back to Cornell straight ahead I used to
it went back for a little bit
the Cornell no I would never did Danford
afterwards and then
since I write to ooh BRR okay I know at
one point in time she tried to recruit
me to come to Ober it was very informal
though and but we stayed in touch and
it's great to have you back to to tell
us today about matching and dynamic
pricing for ride-hailing it's done
thank you so much Eric it's great to be
back at MSR I had an incredible
experience the last time I was here this
right despite the little disruption I
think we really landed with an amazing
project here at MSR in in Redmond
working together with a big Maps team so
I'll talk a bit about maps today but
I'll also I'll focus on the pricing and
matching techniques that you might be
familiar with as a user of ride-hailing
platforms I'm gonna start with a story
about surge pricing so this is an
example of a situation where surge
pricing worked well this is the close of
an ariana grande concert in 2015 in
Madison Square Garden the period in
yellow is the time period in which surge
pricing kicked in because demand was
very high at the end of the at the end
of the event and so on the x-axis we're
looking at time and on the left you can
see the number of ride requests and you
can see that at the end of the game the
number of ride requests does go up surge
pricing kicks in and as we look in the
middle plot we see that the time to pick
up the time between when the rider
requests and when they're picked up by
the driver does increase during this
time period but it only goes from about
two minutes to about three and a half
minutes so still very reasonable on the
right hand side what you're seeing is a
time series of the request completion
rate meaning out of riders who requested
what proportion had a vehicle dispatched
to them and in fact that's number is so
close to one that you can't really see
the purple the purple curve contrast
with an example where we had a surge
outage and this occurred in 2015 New
Year's Eve in New York City
the period of the outage is shown in red
on the Left we're looking at the number
of requests the number of requests
skyrockets during this during this time
period and in the middle we're looking
again at those pick up times and you can
see that the pickup times skyrocket from
about two minutes to about eight minutes
so very long pickup times affecting the
riders and the drivers and when you look
on the right-hand side this is the worst
piece of the picture communication sorry
an outage means that the prices did not
rise during this time period positive
because because our systems went down
basically so you can see that out of
rider requests during the outage fewer
than 25% of those riders were actually
dispatched a car so this is a this is a
failure of our system this is an example
of my first argument which will be that
the matching techniques matching how we
match riders with drivers and riders
with each other and carpools and our and
techniques for dynamic pricing we keep
the the amount of wasted time for riders
and drivers very low in these
ride-hailing systems and ensure
reliability of this service I'll also
show that if that the introduction of
some novel matching approaches could
reduce the variability that's introduced
by dynamic pricing so the downside of
dynamic pricing of course is that it
leads to this variability in prices over
time and a bit of unpredictability in
prices both for riders and for for
drivers so first I'll talk about a bit
of context we'll walk through matching
and dynamic pricing I'll dive deep in
dynamic pricing and I'll talk about how
we estimate the inputs to pricing and
matching algorithms or at least
illustrate how that can be done then
I'll argue that these novel matching
algorithms can could potentially reduce
price variability to the benefit of both
riders and drivers
but first a little bit about my time at
uber I joined over about three years ago
I was leaving the team called
marketplace which creates the pricing
and matching systems for uber and also
all of the inputs to those algorithms
like the predictions of supply and
demand as well as travel time in the
road network which is part of our our
mapping service now I focus on the maps
piece of the picture lightly data
science for uber Maps Maps does a bunch
of different things that Eric mentioned
and here's an illustration of predicted
travel speeds in the Bay Area San
Francisco Bay Area road network I'll
talk a bit about this plot later so most
critically for pricing and matching
techniques the mapping service does
prediction of traffic and and travel
time conditions in real time and
recommends routes and predicts travel
times from point A to point B so if
you're dispatching a vehicle we need to
know how long it would take that driver
to get to that writer so it's a critical
input to the matching systems that we'll
talk about today so I don't think I have
to convince this audience that
ride-hailing has been growing at a
remarkable rate so on the right hand
side we're looking at the volume of uber
trips by year since 2010 this is through
improved convenience and efficiency of
the service and I'll argue that
techniques for matching riders with
drivers and for calibrating demand with
supply through dynamic pricing are
important in creating this growth are
you specifically that these techniques
reduce the amount of wasted time for
riders and drivers on the platform which
creates a seamless service and ensures
that riders and drivers really engage at
high volumes with the platform so if we
look on the left-hand side on the driver
side of the picture
and look at the percentage of time that
drivers send spend with a passenger in
the vehicle that's the time period in
which they're being paid per mile per
minute
and compared taxi service to Ober acts
in three different cities we see
considerably higher utilizations for
uber than for the taxi services in two
out of the three cities New York City is
a slightly different case because of the
density of both taxi and uber in in the
city the utilizations are very similar
in New York City if we look at the rider
side of the picture yes
lower over X this is 2015 data I imagine
it's the pictures changed a little bit
since then New York is flooded with cabs
in some ways so it's it just always
seems like it's a white blob of yellow
in the whole city I'm guessing that the
density of cabs higher in New York City
so that might be it might be there there
might be some I'm not I don't know the
answer to that question it's a great
question then head if you just stick
your arm out of cab stops they don't
know where you are most times a day
except for rain yeah and so that might
put a dent in uber uber is in it just
guessing here's what for
something like one of the drivers a lot
of what I'm doing and what percentage
they just see anyway that's a great
question I don't have data for you in
the presentation we will talk about the
implications of there's these three
states that drivers cycle through and
some of the implications for the
mathematical models but I don't have
empirical data for you on that
Oh on the rider side of the picture
in terms of comparing the amount of
wasted time for riders a waste of time
for a rider is that is the time that
they have to wait between when they
request the ride and when they're picked
up and so this is a simulation
comparison between riding services and
street hailing services in other words
taxi style services so the
curve is the ride hailing services and
the green dotted curve is the street
hailing services and in the simulated
grid the author's saw lower pickup times
for riders on the on the ride hailing
services than on the street hailing
services so you can see less wasted time
both for riders and for drivers you just
put your hand out and the taxi could you
have to wait for the taxi to come so
there are taxis circulating and when
this other rider wants to know how you
see it so if it is 2 meters away from me
in the waiting time is nice so you're
into the time between when the rider
wants the ride and there's a driver
passing by for which they can hail
that's the way the simulation is done
great so the matching in the context of
ride hailing means how do we match
riders with drivers in the case of uber
X for example and how do we match riders
together with each other and with a
driver in these real-time car pools for
uber pool the dynamic pricing piece of
the of the puzzle on the Left I'm
showing the upfront price that's shown
in the uber app and as part of
calculating this upfront price there's
this search multiple so you can think
about a slightly simplified scenario not
quite this simple in practice but think
about paying a base time and distance
per mile in per minute and then when
demand is much higher than supply us the
surge multiple goes above one meaning
that riders are paying that multiple of
the normal time and distance fare and
drivers are being paid that multiple of
the normal time and distance fare
again it's not quite that simple but you
can think about a 2x surge multiple as
being roughly doubling the price for
riders and the payment for drivers and
so and so as we're going to talk today
about how a surge price might be might
be calculated and so we're showing a
heat map of the search multiple on the
right hand side we're darker purple
means a higher surge multiple
great so the simplest matching algorithm
that you could think of would be - as
soon as a writer requests a ride to
simply dispatch the car that can get to
that ride or the fastest that's called
the first dispatch protocol and that's
the dispatch protocol that was used in
the simulation that I showed you before
so even this very simple type of
dispatch protocol does lead to these
these high efficiencies that being said
there's a variety of ways to to decrease
that pickup time even more and I'll show
you an example of one but before I do
that I do just want to point out the
fact that the key input for dispatch
decisions is this prediction of travel
time in the road network how long will
this pickup take for example yeah what
do you compare your when you say if you
take the closest one for example say
this already lowers there as compared to
what this is this comparison is done so
there's a simulation where we're
comparing a call system in other words
of a ride hailing style system with a
street hailing service like a taxi
service how did you get the information
from taxi this is a simulation again is
it it's a there's a grid you Oh on the
x-axis is congestion level meaning how
many riders and drivers did we simulate
in the grid what's the density of riders
and drivers this is not based on on
actual data great so I'll show you a
mechanism that can further reduce these
pick up times it's called trip upgrade
and it's a simple idea so if a rider is
matched with a driver and then another
driver becomes available and another
writer requests a ride it may be
advantageous to all parties if we swap
the match instead of matching rider be
with driver beam so simple concept this
match swapping but
hassed again it has to make everybody's
pickup time lower so here's an
illustration so we'll start from the
beginning
so there's rider a and driver a they're
matched together they have a six minute
ETA and then a second driver and a
second rider appear and the match is
swapped so simple mechanism but you can
see that it decreases the pickup time
for all the parties there's a variety of
different mechanisms like this I'm not
going to get into detail on any others
because I want to dive deep in the
dynamic pricing context we will come
back to matching and tied into dynamic
pricing in the last section so so let's
think about how one might calculate a
surge multiple so somehow this should be
based on local supply and demand
conditions we're somehow trying to
calibrate demand with supply so on the
left-hand side I'm showing a key measure
of demand which is how many riders are
opening the app and checking the price
as a function of geolocation on the
bottom left I'm showing the number of
open vehicles vehicles that are
available to be dispatched and somehow
we need to combine these together with
some other inputs to calculate a search
multiple was there a question in the
back is the search multiple expected not
only to reduce the demand but also
increase the supply is it is it
predictable so that drivers will start
driving when there's a surge that's
that's a great question I what tends to
happen is that drivers know the time
periods and locations in which there
tends to be high surge and you do see
that they they come out and drive more
in at bar close for example or I in
morning or evening rush hour these peak
times and locations yes and it's an
effect that you'd have to see over time
as people learn the surge multiple or
right so okay that's correct there's
more debate about whether they respond
to the surge in a very short-term way
like when they see the surge they can
see the surge heat map but there is a
lot of evidence that they do come out
and drive more at the times on locations
where there tends to be search great so
how might we determine this search
multiple so I'm gonna go back to very
simple concepts from your econ 101 class
we're gonna build on these this this
kind of model doesn't work straight out
of the box so you could imagine there's
a demand curve as a function of price
there's a supply curve as a function of
price and there's a market equilibrium
price where those two intersect here I'm
just neglecting the fact that the
platform takes the Commission for
simplicity but it doesn't fundamentally
change this picture and so we'll use the
concept of producer surplus and consumer
surplus the producer in our case being
the driver and the consumer being the
writer and the so this area in blue is
the is a measure of how much value is
created for the driver the difference
between the amount that the drivers paid
and their basically the their costs
including opportunity costs and on the
the red area is a measure of how much
rider value is created on the platform
in other words the difference between
the value that the rider gains from the
ride and the amount that they're paying
and so if we add up the red area and the
blue area that's called the welfare and
that's a measure of how much value is
created for writers and drivers okay so
it's not this simple in our in in the
context of ride-hailing but we need
these concepts and notice that this
market equilibrium price is the price
that maximizes the welfare okay so in
our context there's three states that
drivers cycle through Michael referred
to this earlier there's the open state
when they're available to be dispatched
there's the enroute state where they're
on their way to pick up a rider and
there's the on trip state so the riders
are sensitive not just to price but also
to
pick up time because that's the wasted
time for them the drivers on the other
hand are sensitive to both open and on
view time because they're not being paid
during that time period they're paid
during this on trip time period so the I
don't think you can get spree the open
time and go to different types of times
having a lot evening like rebalancing
the rebalancing and not so how much oh
that's a great question so how much
rebalancing occurs there is a fair
amount of rebalancing that occurs in
these and these systems sometimes the
drivers do it while they're online and
sometimes they go offline and move and
so we have some visibility into that but
the it's also a little bit tricky to
measure how much rebalancing time
interestingly because if they if they go
out of the app turn off the app and then
come back on in a different location
not necessarily interestingly because
sometimes they they will for example in
San Francisco they drive all the way out
into the suburbs they often want to
rebalance drive into the back into the
city to get more rides but if they leave
their app on while they're driving up
the highway they can be dispatched all
along the way and the drivers report
that that they do better in terms of
earnings if they rebalance all the way
back to the city so which is they do
sometimes go out of the app to move to
change geographic location in response
to perceived earnings difference by
geolocation do you have evidence of
people that are using both lyft drivers
that are lyft and and uber and if you do
is what there's a competitive pressure
on providing a better experience that
would influence the economics here in
terms of competing for the attention of
the drivers yeah the competitive angle
is obviously an important one is a
pretty complicated one yeah so I think
we're gonna leave it aside for the
purposes of this talk but yes there's
definitely it's not this simple
in fact one of the models that the model
that I'll introduce the simplified model
assumes that there's a the number of
drivers that are on the system is a
response just to the to the price and
the earnings and that there's no
competitor in that picture it's a closed
system there's only one geographic
regions I was simplified in a lot of
ways and the competitor in the model
that I'll show is one of the
simplification that is to the side that
this you probably have very strong
evidence by watching these drivers jump
around town well yeah online that
they're actually using to services to
actually Revenue Service it can be hard
to tell if the driver turned off got
went out of app in order to move
rebalance or took a trip on a competitor
for example there's limited visibility
in Tibet yeah conjecture that I thought
was obvious but maybe maybe it's false
that in the matching pricing efficiently
designed them it would never be
individually optimal for a driver to
switch off the app while he balances he
was always in a matching pricing does
efficient I would have thought that he
would always be individually better off
by actually taking three rather than
giving up that opportunity is that is
that theory true um in practice the
drivers report but that means that that
might seem there is a price to mention
pricing that he uses not efficient is
the yeah is the fact that drivers
reported the truth that the system is an
efficient or is my conjecture off yeah I
I think it's I think it's a reasonable
to assume that there are that these
matching and pricing algorithms are not
perfectly efficient in terms of being
incentive compatible and so on
so okay so there's the sense of
sensitivity to pickup time in addition
to price and to the the welfare
maximizing price there's there's
actually a market equilibrium which is a
price and pickup time that maximizes the
welfare for which there's not much
wasted time in the system so so on the
left-hand side I'm showing a situation
where there's not very many writers and
not very many drivers and as you can
imagine the pickup times in this
scenario very long and and so riders and
drivers engage at lower rates with the
platform whereas on the right-hand side
with more riders and drivers in the
system that pickup times are low and the
engagement is high so you'll see that
that the welfare maximizing price and
pickup time combination looks like this
right hand side so here's like let's
let's make that concept rigorous one key
aspect is that there's a very strong
mathematical relationship between the
number of open cars in a particular
geographic region and the pickup time so
here what I'm showing you is we've
picked a particular geographic region
and we've looked at different time
periods and we've gathered data on the
average pickup time and on the number of
open cars during those those time
periods and then for each particular
value of the open cars like 40 open cars
all time periods in which there were 40
open cars we look at what was the
average pickup time and that's what's
shown in the blue curve you can see that
the the pickup time decreases as a
function of the number of open cars and
in fact it fit remarkably well with a
log linear model shown in red so this is
this clear mathematical relationship
between the two another piece that we'll
need is a steady state formula for the
number of cars on trip so if we look at
the trip completion rate capital C and
we multiply by the amount of time the
average length of a trip the average
duration of the trip that gives us the
steady-state number of cars on
so this is an application of littles law
and so what we're going to do in the
next slide is we're going to break down
the number of total cars by the number
of cars that are on trip the number of
cars that are open and the number of
cars that are on route so here you go
the three states and let's for right now
let's take a fixed number of total cars
in fact we'll well in later slides a
note that the number of the number of
the total number of cars is actually a
function of the price and the pickup
time and so on but for right now just
just think about capital n is being
fixed and then decomposed the number of
cars into the number of open cars
capital o the number of on trip cars
which is the product of this trip
completion rate and the the trip time
capital T and then let's apply littles
law again on the right hand side to
calculate the number of cars that are in
this on route or pickup state so that's
the trip completion time trip completion
rate times this pickup time ADA from the
from two slides ago that function
decreasing function as a function of the
number of open cars yes okay so what
we're going to see this is a
mathematical formula for how the
completion trip completion rate must
relate to these numbers but we'll see in
a moment we're going to use this in
order to calculate the trip completion
rate as a function of the number of
total cars and so on just the number of
trips completed per unit time yep in
steady state the number of trips
completed per open time so it's like the
throughput of this system how many trips
are we creating with this the system
yeah
the obvious for state or the driver
which is I am not logged in into the app
but hey I want to get a ping give this a
search happening get open yeah because
you know people take lunches or they're
at home watching the game or you know
why is it a good time to make some money
so I'm wondering if that would affect
your modeling in any way well certainly
there's a sense in which drivers over
the long term will respond to the amount
of money that they're earning and that's
will be built into the model a couple
slides later you're talking about a
shorter term aspect which is if they're
surge pricing right now maybe we should
give a push notification
there is a port state the the so it
turns out that you can capture that
fourth state through modeling capital in
instead of thinking about capital and
the number of cars as being fixed what
we're going to do is we're gonna model
it as a function of the earnings and
that's that's implicitly taking into
account the fact that drivers have
another option which is not to drive it
all question congestion level traffic
and so on certainly does affect the
pickup time and the trip duration
capital T we're not going to focus on
that aspect the this the model that
we'll use will be focused on a
particular time of week so we'll
condition on time of week and so if you
take say take downtown San Francisco in
morning rush-hour traffic conditions are
roughly consistent during that time
period and so then we'll just assume a
background traffic level as we fit these
models and so for example as we were
fitting that that curve for pickup time
versus number of open cars that should
be fit just for morning rush-hour in
that particular geographic area for
example that's a great question yes when
you fit the average pickup time model
what was the source of the variance in
the
the carbs he says was because there is
rush hour or not Russia wizard oh I'm
sure there's there's variability in the
number of open cars simply because first
of all if we assume that the drivers are
arriving according to a Poisson process
and we have a fixed geographic region
the number of cars that arrive is a
Poisson random variable and so there
will naturally be some variability
particularly if we look at a relatively
small geographic region there's some
natural variability in the number of
open cars just due to that Poisson noise
for example there then there's a variety
of additional factors which lead to
additional noise and the number of open
cars you have to control for things like
think some Street was shut down in the
model for pickup time as a function of
open cars yes this this model didn't
explicitly take any subtleties like that
into account it's just a simple
relationship between the two is a
surprisingly good relationship in this
case it seemed to me it seems
surprisingly wide variance and kind of
number the number of open cars who went
from literally zeros yeah well there's
not very many time trees in which we saw
those very high numbers of open cars
which is why I was a little noisier down
on the right-hand side okay yeah so so
the number of open cars that's actual
actual numbers like 36 minutes 36 of
them cars right yeah so what rock quarry
what percentage ah okay how big is the
Geo that this is based on um that's a
great question I think this is roughly a
San Francisco downtown area but I don't
know how big exactly the Geo is so
roughly what's what's a total number of
cars occupy oh oh that are on trip yeah
and so on in other words how does it
roughly break down between the three
space roughly open the odds versus both
car
it's a great question it depends on
whether we're you previously the other
was at you and I'm sorry I just realize
it's 40 wait does he support it about
half the time cars are on treatment
engagements are of the time they're
either open or go to the passenger door
so let's say couple that they're open
sir that sounds strange that there are
so few cars in the entire Soviet area
there are only like most of the time
it's not the whole thing Francisco area
it's some sub region of downtown's that
I don't know how big so let's take that
supply model from this slide and let's
rearrange to put trip completion rate
which is a measure of value created the
number of trips created let's put that
on the left hand side and on the right
hand side the the number of open cars
and this pickup time which is also a
function of the number of open cars and
let's just treat n and T as being fixed
for the moment but again we'll come back
and correct that in a minute so the if
we look at the trip completion rate
capital C as a function of the number of
open cars that's the red curve and then
the blue curve is just the curve that
you looked at before the pickup time and
you can see that the trip completion
rate is non-monotonic that there's an
optimal value o star for the number of
open cars to maximize the trip
completion rate now if you go above for
values of the number of open cars that
are above o star there's a bit of the
trade-off here there's if we if the
number of open cars is higher the trip
completion rate is slightly lower but
then the pickup time is also slightly
lower so there might be an experience
versus throughput trade-off here so so
the so Oh star is one way to think about
an optimal system but maybe there's a
bit of a trade-off and and there's a
consideration around slightly higher
levels of open cars on the other hand if
you go to the left there's really no
advantage at all just disadvantage so we
they'll look at what happens to the left
the number of trips being complete
drops and additionally the pickup time
increases so more wasted time for
writers and drivers fewer trips
completed it's not advantageous to
anyone to be in this zone and I'll call
this the danger zone and you'll see that
it has some really some implications for
for the ability of the system to to
serve riders and drivers okay so that
was a model that just involved the
supply that the cars in different states
yes a danger zone what's the implication
in the danger zone for the earnings per
driver since you have fewer open cars
all the time it would seem that the
drivers would earn more in the danger
zone they actually don't earn more in
the danger zone fewer trips are
completed they spend more time picking
up then they save in terms of they say
spend less time open but they spend much
more time picking up and they're only
paid when they're in there on trip
status and so actually this does not
increase earnings great so let's come
tie back maybe let's keep moving a
little bit and then we'll come back to
the questions so let's tie back to
prices and let's think about in order to
tie in to prices and what and how surge
prices might work let's think about
modeling demand and supply so for
example we need to understand how the
trip requests volume on the writer side
might respond to that pickup time or to
or to the surge multiple and so a simple
model for that could be the following
the number of requests as a function of
the price and the pickup time as the
product of the number of riders who are
opening the app and checking the price
lambda the function for the price
response arm and a function for the ETA
response G and this is a simple model in
which we assume probabilistic
independence between the two for
illustration and if we look at the data
on the bottom the fit actually is pretty
good for these so here's the surge mold
pull on the x-axis and on the y-axis the
probability of request and you can see
that the blue curve is the data at each
of these search multiples and the red
curve is the fit model and so a pretty
good estimate except some interesting
non-monetary cities here around 10
minutes ETA okay so that's a demand
model now let's put some of the pieces
together so in in a steady state model
the number of riders requesting rides
should be equal to the number of trips
that are completing per unit time and so
that demand model on the left-hand side
should equal the number of trips
completing which we derived on the right
hand side additionally I'm not going to
go into detail on this piece but the
number of open cars capital and it
actually depends on how much the drivers
are earning this is what we talked about
before so that's a function of the price
P is also a function of the number of
trips that are completing per per unit
time per driver so solving this system
of equations yields up the pickup time
and the trip completion rate that's
associated with any given price level P
okay and on the next slide we'll look at
that the amount of value the welfare
created at each each price point little
P this is by the way all described in a
paper by Castillo and colleagues and I'm
not describing uber surge pricing system
describing how surge pricing can be done
and the concepts behind it the so let's
look as a function of the surge
multiplier at the amount of welfare
created in the system that's the red
curve I've also shown the curve for the
platform revenue and you can see that
when the surge multiple drops below a
certain level the welfare drops off a
cliff much less welfare is created and
the reason for that is that this is the
danger zone this is the zone in which
because these pickup times get long a
lot of the supply is wasted and
pickup time and it's much much more less
efficient so the welfare maximizing
price is basically just above that
cutoff for the danger zone if the price
drops below that threshold the welfare
drops precipitously these pickup times
go up the time on trip drops the trip
completion rate drops okay so what
happens it's not the supply and demand
conditions fluctuate over the course of
a day and so in red I'm showing a peak
hours again in downtown San Francisco
and in blue I'm showing the non peak
hours in downtown San Francisco and you
can see that the location of this danger
zone is higher for the peak hours than
it is for the non peak hours and the
welfare maximizing price is lower during
those non peak hours than it is during
the peak hours and so the dynamic
pricing system specifically has to keep
the price above this danger zone think
it's so fragile and brittle that you
want to be robust to be variations that
if you're different to your model in
reality so yeah so did you do monitor
active monitoring to see who you are or
do you actually speed try to robust
estimates they don't wait away from the
cliffs so I think you're absolutely
correct that that there's a certain
amount of modeling noise that once you
take a new to account this is kind of
playing right on the edge again this
isn't ubers surge pricing system it's
just an illustration of the concept but
yes in practice if you were to implement
this you would want to take that into
account that that is what is the
opportunity cost for the driver
so VR so sandy multiplier less than one
the driver might be losing money you
know compared to doing something else
and so certainly the supply the
sensitivity is supply to earnings is
part of what went into this model but
it's not just the driver this is not
just the fact that drivers have an
alternative it's due to the fact that
these this pick
time phenomenon where the pickup times
get really low get really high and so
the drivers are not earning money during
those long pickup times it has more to
do with that than it does to do with the
drivers alternatives so one upshot of
this is that dynamic pricing if dynamic
pricing is disallowed meaning that the
same search multiple has to be used for
all times and locations the welfare
maximizing fixed multiple is right up
here with the dynamic price for the peak
hours so you end up set the system would
end up setting a higher price if dynamic
pricing is not allowed which means that
fewer trips are created and less welfare
is created so this is why dynamic
pricing is important in ride hailing
platforms okay so so I'm going to talk a
little bit about how to estimate the
inputs but I also want to have time to
talk about alternative matching
algorithms where are we on time Erik
sounds great thank you all right so
let's come to the back to this demand
model and remember that lambda here is
the rider the arrival rate for rider
sessions over time and per time and and
geographic unit and so we have to be
able to predict what lambda is at least
in the very short term in the next five
minutes in the next ten minutes how many
riders do we expect to open the app and
check their price and I'm going to
illustrate this with New York City Taxi
data which is publicly available
that's because demand data and
geolocation Ford amanda's is sensitive
for privacy reasons but you can see that
in this type of data you get these very
strong Geographic patterns this is
Manhattan you can see much higher demand
in Manhattan than in surrounding areas
and higher demand in the in the peak
times than in the middle of the night
so prediction here's a here's a simple
illustration of prediction short-term
prediction of this demand by time and
geolocation in this case the author's
used a random forest model with
discretization of latitude and longitude
and time with a remarkable degree of
success for a simple approach and so
we're showing here the prediction on the
left and the actual on the right and you
can see that basically captures the
critical features there's more density
of demand in these downtown areas it's
even able to pick up the fact that
there's more demand along the
thoroughfares in Manhattan and is able
to capture those daily cycles
effectively another in the input to the
to the matching algorithms was this
travel time prediction let's just talk
about that for a moment so what does the
data look like for this type of
prediction the prediction is done using
location data from trip so when a driver
has a passenger in the vehicle we have
GPS data during that trip and that's
shown in red for a particular example
the sequence of points starting from top
left to top right and you can see that
in this case it looks like the driver
went through a tunnel there's one GPS
point that has either very large noise
in the latitude longitude or an
incorrect timestamp and so certainly any
algorithms will need to be robust to
that sort of noise so what might how
might one do travel time prediction
using this type of data the first step
is what's called map matching and John
has some wonderful algorithms for this
and the shown in blue is the map matched
trip meaning the route estimated route
and the estimated we also have to
estimate the amount of time that the
driver took to traverse each road
segment in that route and you can see
that this case it did pretty well it
estimated that that the driver went
through the bridge through the tunnel
okay after this data processing step
then you can aggregate by the road
segment level so here the histograms
here these are four histograms for four
particular Road segments this is
actually data from the project at MSR
and for this particular road segment for
example this is looking at all of the
traversals of this road segment during
evening rush hour it's something like
that yeah yeah we all love five ponies
like the old bridge these are the four
most commonly traversed highway road
segments in Seattle I don't remember
exactly and then the the curve is is a
model that can be fit to travel speeds
at the road segment level this is some
particular model that we use for this
project but more generally you can think
about creating a model at the road
segment level and for predicting the
travel time across that road segment
given a set of predictors things like
what is the historical traffic for this
road segment at this time of week was a
historical travel time for this time of
week what's the last fifteen minutes
average for this road segment in terms
of the travel time how's the weather is
it a holiday and so on and so there's
typically a model for road segment
traversal times and then those
individual predictions are going to be
put together to predict the amount of
travel time between an origin and a
destination in a moment great so so now
that we have these segment level models
you can then predict in real time the
travel time on any particular road
segment in the road network and here
this is a showing predicted travel speed
this for the road segments in the San
Francisco Bay Area overlaid on a
satellite photograph green means faster
and red means slower and you can see
that the highways have higher predicted
speed in this example than downtown San
Francisco side roads this is probably
the middle of a night this isn't on
congested time period research area can
you share anything about what you
actually do it Gooper for picking Road
speeds yeah exactly
yeah yeah are you doing you is the is
the probe network from uber itself good
enough good predictions based on
e-ticket multiple sources of data like
we did we have them for clear flow you
know the answer if you can't answer that
question sure maybe let's talk offline
about it thank you the primary data
source would be the East reversal times
for vehicles in the in the road network
how you generalize that to Cygnus where
they're not running so yeah that is the
okay so so Eric's pointing out the fact
that using recent data is a great way to
predict traffic if you're talking about
a highway it doesn't work so well in
some of these areas with very sparse
data and so that a lot of the trick in
traffic modeling is how to deal with
traffic modeling for to areas with
sparse data that's absolutely correct so
oh let's talk about it later great so
then you can put together these
individual travel times to get travel
time from point A to point B in the
following fashion
oh the next step is to compute the
fastest path faith based on those
traffic predictions there's a ton of
different algorithms for this like a
star and hub labeling algorithms and and
so on and then you could simply sum the
travel times across across that route
you could stop there it turns out that
this doesn't work perfectly because you
tend to under predict the amount of
travel time on the route why is that I
guess it's always a stoplights but that
should be incorporated it's a great
great call-out potentially stoplights we
try to incorporate that into the models
but yes that's an issue dynamically
changing dynamic okay so changes over
time so the issue is that there's a
consistent under prediction effect if we
first find the fastest route and then
predict the travel time for that route
and
because drivers don't always take the
fastest route so so there's an under
prediction bias and so typically at this
stage there's some kind of a bias
adjustment or a second model to account
for the fact the drivers are not always
taking the fastest path so it can be
simple as a bias adjustment but again
more sophisticated models are possible
at this stage okay so I do want to come
back to this concept of novel matching
algorithms and how might they they help
in mitigating the variability of price
that's introduced through dynamic
pricing here's a simple mechanism let's
think about choosing a waiting window
call that capital fee that's going to be
on the rider side and this fee could be
dynamic it could depend on supply and
demand conditions so when a rider
requests a ride instead of simply
instead of only looking at the open cars
we're going to consider both the cars
that are open and the cars that are
currently on trip all the drivers on
Trip drivers within few minutes of
completing their trip so we're going to
expand the supply base in that sense and
we're going to dispatch the driver who
minimizes either the time to pick up if
that's an open driver or if it's a
driver that's currently on trip the
amount of time between their drop-off
and the location of that next Rider okay
so let's illustrate that with an example
so here's a writer there's four possible
cars two of which are currently open and
two of which are currently on trip so
this car is five minutes from the writer
so we call that five minutes eight
minutes here and on this side this is a
car that's four minutes from its
drop-off the drop-off location is two
minutes from this Rider and so we're
going to count that as two minutes not
as six minutes okay and then similarly
for this potential match we're going to
count the five minutes and
- seven total minutes and then we're
gonna try to minimize that so in this
case we would dispatch drivers see
because they minimize the time between
this drop-off location and the pickup so
why this mechanism okay notice that this
is this is a dynamic waiting mechanism
it's it's asking drivers to wait a
little bit longer
instead of or in addition to paying a
higher price you can even think about
dynamically adjusting that wait time and
dynamically adjusting the price together
but the main the critical thing to
understand about this mechanism is
basically trying to avoid the danger
zone by optimizing for less wasted time
between trips for drivers so it's asking
the rider to flex a little bit in terms
of their time but it's minimizing the
amount of time that drivers spend
between on their way to pick up riders
this is a similar concept to some of the
flexing ideas in one of Hoover's
products the express pool product where
riders are asked to wait a little bit
longer before they're dispatched a
driver and are also asked to walk a
little bit to meet their driver so what
happens this is a simulation for
downtown San Francisco but it's based on
actual demand and supply data from this
Geo in blue what I'm showing is the
optimal dynamic waiting time if we allow
dynamic weighting and dynamic pricing
and in red I'm showing the optimal
dynamic waiting time if we don't allow
dynamic pricing and you can see that
under the scenario where you have both
dynamic waiting and dynamic pricing you
have pretty reasonable wait times
anywhere between 0 and 4 minutes so not
super high these riders are being asked
to wait up to four minutes longer than
they normally would this scenario where
dynamic pricing is not allowed leads to
very long rider
wait times probably not going to work
from a product perspective so let's go
back to that curve that we looked at
before where we were looking at welfare
as a function of the price multiplier so
you saw this this blue curve before
although I think it was a different
color and this is the curve that showed
how the dangerzone effects shows up as a
function of the surge multiply
multiplier so this is the curve for
welfare as a function of the surge
multiplier and the the blue curve is the
case where we where there's dynamic
pricing but not dynamic rider weighting
and the red curve is the case where both
are included and you can see that the
introduction of this dynamic rider
weighting moves the dangerzone to the
left okay
so reduces the optimal value of the the
surge multiplier and also slightly
increases the total Welfare created so
if we look at the optimal surge
multiplier as a function of the hour of
day the blue curve is the case without
the rider waiting and the red curve is
the case
with the rider waiting you can see that
the the surge multiples are generally
lower and the variability is less in the
search multiple from one time period to
the next
any questions okay never general
question about the sort of
predictability of this system so let's
say you have two consecutive days with
exactly the same conditions in terms of
demand and all that I mean how would the
prices with the prices behave similarly
or all the dynamics will behave similar
I mean think of the notion of
equilibrium in other multiple equilibria
or a single equilibrium in this kind of
a scenarios so single equilibrium given
fixed supply and demand conditions but
the supply and demand conditions do
fluctuate a fair amount even day to day
and so this if you look at the the short
term prediction of demand in fact you
get these little these these local
fluctuations and supply ends in the end
two different days then you'll get the
same search price because the search
price is a function
supply and demand what am I not
understanding oh oh you're saying
because the drivers respond yeah kind of
I'm thinking I'm thinking about the
notion of you know in NASH setting like
unique equilibrium is there unique
equilibrium yes yes so for a given price
point there is an equilibrium value for
the waiting time under fixed supply and
demand conditions yeah there's a theorem
about that I didn't include it in the
talk great so to conclude this growth of
ride-hailing is is facilitated by these
matching and pricing algorithms these
algorithms reduce the wasted time for
both writers and for drivers
they require forecasts of demand of
supply and travel time we talked about
how one might generate those forecasts
we also talked about how introducing
different matching algorithms might be
able to help decrease the price
variability associated with dynamic
pricing and then there's this meta point
around the fact that this isn't just
machine learning that we're doing it's a
mix of economic models statistical
approaches machine learning and
optimization thanks very much so
regarding the new matching you showed so
where you look at the top of time when
you measure only the distance so that
there is a cut-off because maybe there
is a drop-off the cutoff is capital is
fee so that is that that's what we're
flexing is the maximum amount of extra
weighting that we would require from the
rider and the second question I had was
more open-ended I'm I'm thinking like in
terms of the drivers like he's there you
have a data where what is the amount
money made by the each driver is it fair
across all the drivers or
okay so fairness of earnings drivers
policies can determine which driver will
be dispatched to the customer so it
explicitly does not take into account
the fairness from the drivers or
something so it depends on what you mean
by fairness in the those are fair
mechanisms in the sense that nothing is
specific to that driver right that the
the mechanism to discussed here are all
mechanisms that have only to do with the
distance between a rider and a driver
for example they're not personalized in
any sense so they're fair in that sense
you fairness is perhaps a longer
discussion if you wanted to say okay if
you're trying to create earnings that
are as similar across drivers as
possible and to reduce variability
across drivers as much as possible
that's that's an interesting question
and a longer one to address but it says
like roughly speaking they make the
average amount of money weight but the
driver see they don't pay the same there
is there's some data for that publicly
available in in papers I don't have that
on the tip of my tongue oh yeah I had a
question about how do you assess the
demun say if I'm just opening my app and
checking for prizes right I'm not
investing it does that go into the table
yes so that's exactly what lambda was in
this model for so predicting demand even
know so it basically basically assumed
the number of riders opening the app and
checking the price is go is just a
function of time and geolocation it's
not a function of what price I searched
multiple we happen to have right now and
then we assume that the chance of the
writer requests after they're shown the
price does depend on what price you
showed them that's how we break it down
and so then so then this this prediction
we have this prediction of number of
riders opening the app and checking the
price yes
write a script which keeps pinging the
service does that mean the prizes for
everyone else around it so we are very
we're aware that that people could do
this and so we have sit guards in place
to avoid them specifically this and that
so it seems natural that wants to is
start allowing once you start having
writers be willing to wait a little
while that the price bolts wall could
come down a little bit I was wondering
if you guys looked at other matching
mechanisms I'm curious about like for
instance if someone says that they're
willing to wait longer you could just
sort of have them sit around for a while
and then see what other customers have
popped up at the same time what cars are
available then and then do the matching
in kind of a delayed fashion great so so
the question was around asking riders to
wait a little bit longer to be matched
and whether giving rider is the option
to wait a little bit longer might
instead of asking them to pay more could
be advantageous so ii worked there about
the last section you just talked about
the mitigating price variability so you
have this mechanism where people can
wait a little longer and the way you do
the matching is based on sort of where
what cars are going to be close to them
at that point
uh-huh in the future right but I can
propose an alternative mechanism where
the customer says you know I'm willing
to wait a couple minutes extra so you
you you wait the couple minutes and then
see what other customers have shown up
around them and what other cars run and
then do the matching it seems like this
to be another simple alternative I'll
just curious if the one that you showed
is kind of the best among many that
you've explored or it's just really
early in the exploration of these things
it turns out it's the one that's easier
to analyze which is why I used it in
this simplified mathematical model but
you're absolutely correct that this sort
of batching mechanism could be valuable
I think lyft talks about doing it on one
of their blogs but I'm not a hundred
percent certain about that and certainly
in express pool it's something that
driver riders see they they request a
ride and then and then there's some time
before they're actually matched to to a
driver so yes absolutely this is used by
these ride hailing services is
how creative is the TV campus race tell
me new mechanisms for example yeah I've
been on the road where I killed to pay a
lot more for a faster ride it's like
give me enough to pay more for pasture
and that was happening through the whole
system it's a new models like people
people will use to pay higher prices
even an auction model just prefer
getting a faster ride yeah is it is it
easy to suggest and test to experiment
with new ideas like this or just really
be very conservative in terms it's like
you roll things out well I would uh
there have been a variety of products
that have been introduced that
specifically leveraged this difference
between drivers and their trade off
between waiting time and price and I
would argue that the fact that there's
Express pool and pool and uberx is
exactly exactly providing that
flexibility to riders you know in terms
of introducing a new product there is a
user interface change would you have to
be a little bit careful about showing a
fourth option when it's already a lot of
options but in terms of the fast pay
twice as much adjusting you know some of
the backend mechanisms is a little bit
more easier to explore what all right
thanks so much
[Applause]